[Applaus]
hallo schön gute starter zurück aus und
sind auf dem markt jetzt mal mehr leute
seien
erst mal
großartig berlin bettina muss sie ja
schon eher los aber die zahlen sind ganz
ganz wunderbar herzlichen glückwunsch
auch wenn wir noch nicht wissen wie das
endergebnis ausgegangen ist großartig
berlin und auch was wir aus mecklenburg
vorpommern sicher heute abend
und vielen dank euch ein
kompromiss könnte es
nur stellvertretend für unsere 120.000
mitglieder hier stehen danke euch allen
danken raus in die republik wir haben
ein wahlkampf gemacht gespürt wie wir
ihn noch nie in diesem land erlebt haben
rund um die uhr bis gestern nach letzte
sekunde wand so viele unterwegs wir
haben über 100 town holz gemacht mit
tausenden von menschen die vorbereitung
dafür tag und nacht von euch danke diese
town holz das war wirklich großartig und
vor allem da wo wir gemeinsam auftreten
könnten
robert war immer die besonderen momente
vor ort zu sein abends in frankfurt oder
zum abschluss in düsseldorf
und dabei so viele menschen zu spüren
die gar keine grünen mitglieder waren
sondern ganz viel interessierte wo man
gespürt hat da gibt es eine sehnsucht
nach politischer debatte und vor allen
dingen der sehnsucht nicht von
denjenigen die schon 40 50 60 jahre alt
sind sondern an drittklässler
viertklässler nicht nur auf den preis
for future die muss sondern auf den
veranstaltungen bei uns wir haben eine
freistunde wir sind vorbeigekommen war
mal hören wollten das bei euch
eigentlich los ist